comment des élus une élite peut rallier
le peuple pour faire en sorte que ce
peuple se reconnaissent dans des
institutions et en fait si on en fait
rapidement l'histoire et c'est
intéressant de voir ce qui s'est passé
dans sa première élection c'est il ya
trois grosses grosso modo il ya trois
méthodes il ya une première méthode qui
est la plus simple et la plus efficace
est acheté les voix s'appelle le
clientélisme donc ça marche assez bien à
marcher longtemps ça nécessite pas les
aztèques de l'argent mais avec des
promesses avec
ça peut se faire avec de l'art euros ça
peut se faire en place son petit dernier
voilà de tels endroits donc clientélisme
notons d'ailleurs que dans toutes les
démocraties l'abstention augmente quand
le clientélisme baisse le clientélisme
le meilleur exemple c'est ce qu'on va
voir au salon de l'agriculture ça c'est
du client t il en a toujours mais il y
en a eu beaucoup plus disputé un bon la
deuxième méthode c'est la méthode
classique le parti le parti le vrai
c'est à dire le parti communiste c'est à
dire créer une société bis ou dans
laquelle on fait tout on va se marier on
va on va partir en vacances et danser
sautiller débit sa vocation petit à
petit a remplacé la laverai société et
donc pas dans cette dans ce parti tout
se fait y compris éduquer la formation
des élus la formation des militants est
quelque chose d'essentiel bon on l'a vu
ces deux méthodes l'unsa se fait plus
bon client 10 ans n'a plus le droit
l'autre le parti s'effondre et donc dans
cette élection de macron il s'est passé
là mais rj ans d'une nouvelle méthode
qu'on a du mal à identifier mélenchon à
certains égards et est aussi le
représentant d'une méthode sim identique
c'est le mouvement c'est à dire d'une
configuration exceptionnelle
à un moment donné qui produit une
machine électorale mais qui n'a pas
vocation véritablement a duré alors dans
le mode start up pour mac row dont le
mode coopérative pour mélenchon et puis
après ça s'arrête d'une certaine façon
le mouvement s'arrête alors la question
de savoir c'est est ce qu'on va revenir
au parti ou est-ce que qu'elle va être
cette cet instrument ce mouvement dont
on peut dire d'ailleurs que les gilets
jaunes ont été un mouvement un peu
inverse à certains égards parce que dans
en marche ça a marché si je puis dire
mais ça aussi laissé beaucoup de gens de
côté
à
[Musique]